mein thema heute abend ist frieren ist
nicht solidarisch machen wir mal ein
gedankenspiel stellen sie sich vor sie
gehen ins büro mit mütze handschuhen und
daunenjacke bepackt und sitzen dort den
ganzen tag gewarnt sie können sich
gedanklich ehrlich gesagt schon darauf
einstellen denn diesen winter könnte so
weit sein öffentliche gebäude dürfen ab
ende kommender woche in der regel nur
noch bis maximal 19 grad beheizt werden
bisher lag die empfohlene
mindesttemperatur für berufs bei 20 grad
durchgangs bereiche die flure foyers der
technikräume sollen möglichst gar nicht
mehr geheizt werden und auch für private
unternehmen gibt es regelungen die
bundesregierung hat die temperatur
grenzen der arbeitsstätten richtlinie
geändert um schnell kommen high zusammen
signifikant gas zu sparen auch die
regelungen in mietverträgen über eine
mindesttemperatur werden vorübergehend
ausgesetzt was kommt da auf uns zu wenn
man erst mal 19 grad denkt man sich na
ja worüber regt man sich denn überhaupt
auf aber was passiert denn eigentlich
bei weniger als 20 grad raumtemperatur
mit uns viele menschen fangen an zu
frieren bei 18 grad besteht sogar die
gefahr sich zu erkälten auch kann sich
schimmel in den räumen bilden frierend
für den frieden ist das motto dieser
tage doch ich finde dass es alles andere
als solidarisch vor allem mit blick auf
den energieverbrauch der wirtschaft ist
die angestrebte energieersparnis nicht
mehr als vielleicht nur symbolpolitik
auch arbeitnehmerverbände wie die ig
metall schlagen bereits alarm und
sprechen von einer gesundheitsgefährdung
herr janitschek können sie die verbände
verstehen die sich jetzt schon vehement
dagegen aussprechen kann sehr ehrlich
gesagt nicht so richtig verstehen ich
glaube 19 grad jetzt in der
arbeitsstätte beispielsweise ist
verkraftbar man muss ja jetzt auch nicht
mehr im t shirt herum sitzen den ganzen
winter und wir müssen nun mal ein stück
weit runter kommen von den hohen
verbräuchen 20 prozent müssen wir als
gesamt volkswirtschaft einspannen
energie um sicher durch den winter zu
kommen gasspeicher werden gerade voll
gemacht auf der anderen seite braucht
auch leistungen mir schon klar dass
natürlich jetzt der einfache bürger das
nicht in erster linie schultern kann
aber natürlich büros wirtschaft
entsprechend die sollen das machen und
die ein oder andere maßnahme die nicht
bequem erscheint die muss man auch
kommen weil wir müssen dieses ziel
erreichen 20 prozent wir haben eine
krise wie viel energie ersparnis bringt
es uns wenn wir jetzt auf diese 19 grad
gehen wo die arbeitnehmerverbände ja
schon sagen dass man friert also und die
waren jetzt auch schon vor hohen
krankheit ständen wie die ig metall zum
beispiel gewarnt wird ja auch immer viel
das kennen wir aus gronau zeiten und
insofern würde ich sagen 19 grad ist
verkraftbar und es gibt ja auch noch die
möglichkeit eben nicht ein t shirt
anzuziehen sondern ein pullover wenn man
arbeitet wenn man meint dass man friert
ist bin ich mal hat ja in der antwort
und wird es mir selber auch zutrauen ja
und insofern würde ich sagen zwei grad
einsparungen sind halt nunmal dann zehn
prozent gasmenge also und das wissen wir
und da wir das wissen und nicht im
februar darstellen wollen dann alles
abschalten dass mich die alternative
glaube ich brauche mal die maßnahmen
wenn es gut läuft wir kommen mit dem lg
im winter dann früher rein dann kann man
auch wieder drüber nachdenken maßnahmen
zu lockern aber wir haben auch einen
riesen preis momentan die leute zahlen
müssen das heißt energie einsparen heißt
ja auch geld sparen auch für den
privaten übrigens sie sprachen gerade
alternativen eine janacek das ist ein
wichtiges wort und mich wundert dass es
bei der ganzen debatte um das thema
eigentlich eine alternative gibt die
ihre partei überhaupt nicht zur kenntnis
nimmt und eigentlich permanent vor sich
hertreibt und sagt es gibt einen
gesellschaftlichen konsens und deswegen
nutzen wir diese alternative nicht da
geht es um das thema kernkraft und
letzten drei meiler die sicherlich das
problem am ende nicht komplett lösen
aber die sicherlich dazu beitragen
könnten dass das was sie auch gerade
beschrieben haben und nina schenk
natürlich nicht ganz so dramatisch
ausfällt
wie es dann möglicherweise ausfällt dann
wenn wir diese drei meiler die wir haben
zum ende des jahres abschalten dann
brauchen wir mehr gas für die
verstromung also die stromproduktion
mehr dreckige kohle und deswegen noch
einmal die frage auch an sie er könnte
das mit ihrem gewissen eigentlich
vereinbart den menschen zu sagen wir
gehen hier runter auf 19 grad in einigen
sogar wenn es schwere tätigkeiten sie in
einigen betriebsstätten auf 12 grad und
gleichzeitig nehmen wir drei
funktionierende sehr sichere wieder
typisch sagt kernkraftwerke einfach vom
netz also was bayern angeht wo ich
herkomme münchen haben wir ja nicht nur
eine glasglocke sondern möglicherweise
durchaus auch eine stromlücke und
deswegen ist dort die diskussion
aufgrund der sonder beschaffenheit auch
durch die staatsregierung verursacht
über jahrzehnte so dass das sehr
ernsthaft zu prüfen ist ob isar 2 nicht
verlängert werden muss das wird gerade
geprüft das wird seit 1 das geben sie
wünschen sich dass es verlängert wird
ich bin da im einklang auch mit übrigens
meiner grünen stadtratsfraktion in
münchen gesagt wir müssen das sehr
ernsthaft prüfen weil das szenario sein
kann dass wir da in knapp prüfend etwas
anderes verlängern ist die frage die
frage ist ob sein mussten das wird er
jetzt gerade geprüft das wird ein
ergebnis geber ist noch mal ein ganz
gutes sein fett weg was die frage sein
muss also die dreckige kohle die muss
sein und die co2 nahezu co2 freie
kernkraft da ist man sich nach sechs
wochen stresstest immer noch nicht
sicher ob das sein muss und das verstehe
ich nicht wenn man gleichzeitig sagt
liebe bürger nina schenk hat das ja sehr
zugespitzt formuliert ihr müsst frieren
aber bei der kernkraft für die jetzt
übrigens 70 prozent für ein paar erwerb
der bürger für einen längeren für
längere laufzeiten sind übrigens auch
die mehrheit der grün wähler 54 prozent
sind auch dafür kernkraftwerke länger
laufen zu lassen da sagen sie ja das
müssen wir noch prüfen warum kein klares
ja weil die entscheidung schon zu
treffen ist ob wir auch die
sicherheitsrisiken die sehr wohl gibt in
kauf nehmen wollen weil wir durchaus
auch im gesellschaftlichen konsens
hatten und jetzt noch einen punkt ja sie
sagen natürlich würde jetzt der bürger
damit 20 grad heiß und können statt mit
19 übrigens keiner in der wohnung auch
22 machen wenn er will dann bezahlen wir
das nicht wollen also der punkt ist am
ende da ist die kernkraft etwas was
vielleicht zwei prozent von den 20
prozent liefern könnte und das war es
dann schon also die summe die erbracht
werden kann in der kalkulation der
risiken ist so gering dass man das schon
ganz genau angucken muss und wie gesagt
bayern muss man ganz genau angucken da
ist eine problemlage woanders ist die
problemlage also nicht da wir bleiben
noch einmal bei dem bei dem grundthema
frierend für den frieden ja also sie
sind ja der überzeugung die forschung
soll sich den pullover die daunenjacke
bald mit ins büro nehmen und am besten
noch die mütze aufsetzen wir sehen sie
das denn wenn ich jetzt in den
friseursalon g und meine haare gewaschen
kriege und die dann nur noch kalt
gewaschen kommen muss ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich möchte diese einschränkung
nicht haben ja also es natürlich schon
so dass sich das nicht vermeiden lässt
im friseurhandwerk
auf strom oder wärme zu verzichten ist
natürlich auch wenn ich die haare föhne
und das ist schon auf jeden fall ein
punkt der wird auch wahrscheinlich viele
andere handwerksberufe betreffen
ansatz verstehen ich kann ihnen die
beide seiten wissen verstehen und auf
der einen seite möchte natürlich als
kundin ich fühle mich auch nicht
erkälten auf der einen seite will ich
auch verpflichtet dem nachzukommen dass
ich da glauben sie dass die leute da
noch kommen also wenn ich mir jetzt
vorstelle dass ich die haare in der
calle waschen träger und der
friseursalon auch kalt ist muss ich
ehrlich sagen dann weiß ich nicht ob
besorge ich mir was sie bei mir zu hause
selber also ist das nicht auch ein
problem das vielleicht einen kunden
sagen brauche ich gar nicht mehr
das hoffe ich nicht dass das passiert
weil ja das handwerk ja auch eine
relevanz hat entweder anderer hinsicht
aber ich würde schon sagen also zum
thema strom
das wird langfristig für die
handwerksbetriebe auch ein finanzielles
thema sein und
ich hoffe natürlich nicht dass die
kunden sagen das wird ihm zu kalt aber
ich denke es wird ihren anderen stellen
problematiken geben was dann die
unternehmer spüren werden herr doktor
doktor zu weil sie wissen ich betone
beim doktor sie sind der einzige gast
zwei hat er jemals war sehen sie das
denn freund also nicht freuen aber ist
für sie frieren für den frieden
solidarischen wie sehen sie die heutigen
beschlossenen maßnahmen also hier kommt
da immer etwas anderes wir den kopf und
es war vielmehr gesagt wir würden die
frau merkel vermissen ja und ich
verfluche sie jetzt ehrlich sagt jeden
tag mal ganz hart gesagt weil sie hat
die atomkraftwerke er abgestellt klar
ursprünglich war es meine entscheidung
von spd und grünen die hat uns abhängig
gemacht vom russischen gas letztlich
dann die kohlekraftwerke abgestellt
fracking gibt es nicht ja und das sind
jetzt alles die folgen die wir ausbauen
müssen ich finde es auch nicht richtig
wenn man sagt jetzt frieren für den
frieden das so so ist es ja sicher wenn
wir diese ganzen maßnahmen nicht gehabt
hätten also die atomkraftwerke würden
noch laufen jetzt nicht nur ein bisschen
länger ist und generell hätte man die
nicht abgeschaltet sie habe man hätte
auch mit den kohlekraftwerken erstmal
ein stück gewartet habe man hat uns
nicht so abhängig gemacht form vom
russischen gas ja man hätte fracking
zugelassen da hätten wir keines dieser
probleme jetzt und das ist erst mal was
mir so politisch durch den kopf geht ja
ganz persönlich muss sagen bei mir in
der wohnung ist es immer unglaublich
waren ja die meisten leute beschweren
sich wenn sie kommen sagen dass bei dir
viel zu warm aber ich habe auch noch
eine klimaanlage die man auch zur not
auf wärme stellen kann dann zusätzlich
und werde alle stricke reißen habe ich
sogar noch eine
holzsorten von kokowääh mich noch nie
benutzt hat also ich frage mich
eigentlich auch wo sie das gerade sagen
herr titel man sind eigentlich viele
länder um deutschland herum bekloppt
dass die jetzt auch die kernkraft
ausbauen also mit welcher hybris gehen
die deutschen grünen eigentlich heran
und sagen wir müssen erst noch mal
prüfen ob das überhaupt geht wenn um uns
herum ganz ganz viele länder sagen wir
bauen sogar neue kraftwerke wir
verlängern laufzeiten wie belgien kanada
bezieht einen großteil seines stroms aus
der kernkraft sind die alle gaga oder
oder was ist da los also jetzt mal ihre
meinung es wird sein 999 wird dieser
große deutsch wege predigt wir sind
vorreiter bei der energiewende wenn ich
mich auf der welt umschauen
23 jahre später
sehe ich eigentlich kein einziges land
ehrlich gesagt was aus der kernkraft
ausstieg aus der kohle und 80 prozent
seines stroms mit
energien aus erneuerbaren also wind und
sonne eher hinbekommen möchte und das
jetzt schon seit 23 jahren das heißt
schlafen die alle sind die alle
bescheuert sind nur die grünen in
deutschland schlau oder oder sind
möglicherweise die grünen deutschland
gar nicht so schlau sondern für pendler
was ich darf noch mal als draufgabe
vorstand eugen also es ist doch auch so
man hatte mir von grüner seite gesagt
nicht nur vor den grünen wir müssen
jetzt so vorbildlich sein und das so
toll machen unsere energiewende dass
dann die ganze welt sich das ab guckt ja
also wir waren ein bisschen die oberliga
meister der welt am deutschen wesen soll
die welt genesen hat man früher auch
schon mal jetzt laufen die aber statt
als ober predigers oder bettler laufen
die klare kiste gleichen leute durch die
welt von einem land zum anderen
geschehen und wir müssen heute nicht
immer sie reden sondern wir können mit
ihnen reden und deswegen natürlich die
frage einer jahre jack spitz formuliert
ja sind sie denn knapp geworden dabei
also die energiekrise die leute haben
die haben wir ja nicht deswegen weil wir
keine atomkraftwerke haben sondern weil
wir abhängig sind vom russischen gas und
auch rtl exporten und wir zahlen jetzt
als staat sie als bürgerinnen und bürger
darf man mal sagen 34 milliarden euro
für die gast umlage bis 2024 also das
ist das geld was wir erst mal zusätzlich
aufbringen müssten zudem paar milliarden
die schon gezahlt wurden das sind
gigantische beträge zur atomkraft in
europäischen union gibt es die hälfte
der staaten die hat die die andere hat
sie nicht die franzosen haben ganz viele
müssen ganz viele gerade abschalten weil
nämlich ihr doppel haben wasser ist
nicht mehr an den flüssen den fahrgästen
gewartet werden wir müssen denen auch
strom exportieren wollen eine reine die
buchloer es ist also man kann sich dafür
entscheiden die zu haben ich würde das
auch respektieren das wird auch in der
welt zu bleiben wir als bundesrepublik
deutschland haben uns im parlament mit
über 90 prozent der stimmen damals
entschieden auszusteigen das ist der
beschluss der auch von keiner
wahrscheinlich an unserer moral
also ich hab das ja immer für mich
hauptsächlich ökonomisch argumentiert
weil ich der überzeugung bin dass die
atomkraft sehr teuer ist auch die
endlagerfrage ist sehr teuer und ich die
erneuerbaren energien ja jetzt in der
stromgestehungskosten
machen wir auch guten wasserstoff jetzt
mit kanada so günstig sind dass es
überhaupt keinen sinn mehr macht neue
kraftwerke zu bauen also die diskussion
ist für mich um es geht allerdings noch
darum zu recht fragen sie das nochmal
mit den drei den ort da sind da geht es
dann aber auch nur noch darum machen wir
noch ein paar monate und ich mache was
ein paar jahre weil für die gaskrise
hilft uns die atomkraft nichts dafür
müssen wir die erneuerbaren ausbau
effizienter werden und leider auch ein
stück reifer anderes karl ein haufen auf
der kollege boris planer welt zb
weiterlaufen lassen das darf er ja auch
wolle er wieder öfter mal was haben als
licht immer wieder alles normal dann bei
einem wirklichen janitschek also das
heißt drumherum alle die belgier die
jetzt verlängern die franzosen sie sogar
neu bauen die briten die kanadier die
die auf kernkraft setzen das kann doch
nicht also eine partei die das für sich
in anspruch nimmt so wie sie sagen und
sagt 2011 haben wir das mit 90 prozent
mehrheit im bundestag beschlossen die
situation wie sie gerade selbst
geschildert haben ist doch heute eine
völlig andere da war ich mich wo ich die
lernfähigkeit der grünen da sind
offenbar große teile der bevölkerung die
2011 auch für den kompletten
atomausstieg warnt doch viel weiter
haben sich doch geändert hat sagen doch
wir sehen das anders und ich sehe auch
dass überhaupt nicht dass sie sagen wir
lassen das nur ein paar monate
weiterlaufen wenn der deutsche tüv der
tüv süd sagt es gibt kaum sicherer
kernkraftwerke auf der welt als die
deutschen kernkraftwerke wir haben auch
noch drei abgeschalteter zum
jahreswechsel warum berauben wir uns
eigentlich freiwillig dieser
energiequelle denn eins ist auch klar
das was robert habeck und ihre partei
plant in der ampel die die erneuerbaren
energien und die dtm
kapazitäten bis 2030 ja von heute zu
verdoppeln also in einer von acht jahren
ob das klappt oder nicht das steht in
den sternen das weiß niemand und nun mal
für den fall das klappt nicht was machen
wir eigentlich dann also wir sind ja
völlig klar dass wir für
versorgungssicherheit sorgen und dass
wir dafür sorgen dass der ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien drastisch
stattfindet er ist ja heute schon bei
fast 50 prozent deswegen ist die
situation ja auch wenn wir 2011 wir
haben ja jetzt sehr hohen anteil
erneuerbarer im netz und den können wir
gut gebrauchen zurzeit und wenn sie
sagen immer die ganze welt macht die
ganze welt macht eben nicht manche
machen